so what do we know about what caused the
blast the initial fire broke out
late on tuesday afternoon in the port
the cause of that blaze is still
unconfirmed local media reports pointed
to a
fireworks storage facility and video
capturing the fire showed
popping and colored flashes amid the
smoke
other media reports mentioned welding
work that was taking place in a
warehouse nearby
what we do know is that the fire
triggered a huge
explosion at around 6 pm which struck
with a force
of a 3.5 magnitude earthquake and was
reportedly felt
more than 125 miles away in
cyprus that colossal force
was caused by the explosion of 2750 tons
of ammonium nitrate a highly reactive
chemical
which is being stored unsafely in a
hangar
in the pores the industrial chemical is
normally used
in agriculture as a fertilizer but also
in explosives it's an
oxidizer which means it helps fuel to
burn by drawing oxygen to it
enhancing combustion reactions
in stable conditions it is hard to
ignite but can be detonated
if exposed to heat in a confined space
or contaminated
with other substances the question is
what was it doing there it's believed to
have come from a russian-owned cargo
vessel
flying a moldovan flag
the russo's ship left the black sea port
of batumi
in georgia bound for mozambique in
september 2013
carrying more than 2 700 tons of the
chemical
but it was forced to dock in beirut in
2013
after technical problems where it was
then detained
after failing an inspection by port
authorities
it was eventually abandoned by its owner
and crew
and its potentially lethal cargo
offloaded
to hangar 12 in the port where it has
remained
ever since the head of the port and
customs says
several letters were sent to the
judiciary of the last six years
asking for the material to be removed
but no
action was taken a document believed to
be one of those letters
is circulating on social media it
appears
to request permission from the judiciary
to export the chemical cargo from the
warehouse
an investigation has been announced and
a number of port officials
placed under house arrest the country's
prime minister
has pledged to find those responsible
and punish them